this is a production of Cornell
University
great well I just want to say thanks to
Ginny for inviting me
um and to uh Lucille and juping for uh
doing all the logistics so I really
appreciate all the effort
um so thanks
um I'm just going to give kind of an
overview
um of myself and who I am and then
um the land Institute and what we do and
then my program at the land Institute in
particular
um hopefully for the students who I met
with prior to this it's not super boring
because they they've already heard a lot
of it at this point
um but
I think it's really important to think
about all of the all of the things that
happen
um sort of adjacent to plant breeding
that make plant breeding effective in
the world and
um I think that's kind of the summary of
the work that I do so
let me see if I can
okay so first I'll just talk a little
bit about my background and who I am um
obviously I work at the land Institute
but
um I started out in other places I I
actually did my bachelor's
um in physics and math and worked as a
geophysicist for an oil field services
company for many years
um so I think I think this is actually
one of the vessels that I that I worked
on
um we we were a company that builds maps
of the subsurface geology of the ocean
floor and then sells them to oil
companies essentially
um and I got to travel a lot it was
really good I I in in that sense it
really helped me be exposed to different
cultures
um and when I was so I worked on in like
20 countries and five different
continents and at that time it really
gave me
um
a strong interest in food and Food
Systems so these are some of my favorite
dishes from some of my favorite
countries
um that I got to visit I I found myself
talking to people at markets a lot
um working uh visiting Farms
um I just became really interested in
agriculture and Food Systems at that
point
um but I was tired of living on a boat
and got tired of traveling all the time
I was lonely so I ended up quitting that
job
and moved and started working on a farm
in Ecuador where I really became
interested in
both organic farming and Seed systems
and Seed sovereignty so that was the
first time I'd ever thought about seed
and where seed came from
um yeah so became really inspired by by
the folks who were doing that work
um so I came back to the U.S I I was at
that time living in Ecuador and
um as I told the students this morning I
I was not cut out for living in the
tropics I need a seasonal die off of
insects that are biting in particular so
I moved back to
um back to a higher latitude to Wyoming
where where I originally lived and
um did a second Bachelor's in
agroecology at the University of Wyoming
primarily taking uh some Agricultural
and soils courses and things so that I
could get into grad school
um at the University of Wisconsin where
I did a PhD in plant breeding and plant
genetics
um I worked with organic seed Alliance
for about nine months after my PhD where
I really was focused on looking at kind
of the economics of seed systems so
um building Enterprise budgets for
different seed crops I'm thinking
through like the the planning and Seed
scale up and Seed systems and things
like that which gave me
um kind of a unique skill set I think to
work with the land Institute I was hired
as the commercialization manager
um but as that program developed it was
sort of and as our our mission and
vision kind of came into alignment it
was clear that we weren't really
interested in becoming a seed company or
a vertically integrated Grain Company or
something like that that we were really
committed to staying a research
organization and so rather than
commercialization we moved into
stewardship and and crop stewardship so
I'll talk a little bit more about that
as we go
the land Institute itself is a 501c3
primarily philanthropically
um funded we are you know we do have
some funds from from government grants
and
um those are generally like you know
restricted to specific projects but the
primary you know kind of operating funds
for the organization are are through
philanthropic dollars
um our work is done in Central Kansas
kind of smack in the middle of uh Kansas
on the Pawnee Osage and Ka lands
um
our mission is to develop a perennial
diverse agriculture that saves soil from
being poisoned and lost while promoting
a community life at once prosperous and
enduring so this is this is kind of a
big mission right we we have everything
from from social science
um to plant breeding and
um soil ecology and things and I'll talk
about kind of each of the
individual programs here in a little bit
um why we do this um
each
each place and each of the collaborators
that we work with will have kind of a
different why about what they about how
this work impacts them so this is a
photograph of Kansas
um where the biggest kind of issue
facing producers is soil erosion so this
is this is an annual Wheat Field
um on the left and occurs a field on the
right
um after a rain so you can see just the
the washout of topsoil so that's that's
sort of the why of perennial grain crops
in Kansas
in Minnesota the Y is more related to
nitrates in drinking water so the folks
that we work with there are really
concerned with
um with water quality and and drinking
water so the Minnesota Department of AG
for example funds a lot of
um kinds of plantings on Wellhead
protection areas and things like that to
help remediate water that has high
nitrate levels
um in places like Ukraine we have
collaborators who are really interested
in resilience to socio-political
disruption
um so for annual grains
um if you weren't able to get in your
field because because of the invasion of
Russia there's the potential that a
perennial may may have been able to be
more resilient to that socio-political
upheaval
um and then in places like Colorado
we're working with producers and
researchers who are really interested in
the
um the the tolerance to drought and and
also to you know just limited irrigation
and different shutoff dates and you know
essentially the recovery of these
cranial grain plants
um compared with annuals um in times of
drought stress
so this is sort of why are we looking at
perennial grains and why are we focused
on perennial agriculture we want to
build systems
um for agriculture that mimic natural
systems that have the kind of resiliency
to these disruptions
um whether they're socio-political or
climate related
of course you know perennials
why they're resilient to this is that
you know you have reduced need for
tillage reduced soil loss from erosion
um as you can see the on the left here
this is a
a perennial wheat so this is a hybrid
between intermediate wheatgrass and and
Durham wheat and the roots are much
longer than the annual winter wheat so
we're looking at you know potentially
increased carbon
excuse me if I have to cough I
I'm recovering from covid
um so you know increased water water
infiltration and carbon storage
um
pollutant runoff soil organic matter
um increased weed competition that can
reduce the need for spraying and then of
course like increased biodiversity in
terms uh especially of you know
um the soil microbial community and
um the kinds of above ground like
animals and nesting birds and
um and other like nesting insects that
that benefit from reduced tillage
so we do this
um through five different program areas
so the first thing that we do is we
develop perennial grain crops um so this
this uh top grain is perennial rice
we've collaborated for many years with
unan University in China
um they have released several varieties
of perennial rice
that have resulted in yields that are
similar to annual rice yields and and at
this point I think they're they've had
eight um harvests from these fields that
have this perennial race
um silphium integrifolium is a crop
that's native to which is this next one
to the left
um is a crop that's native to the United
States so Central kind of the central
plains basically from the Appalachians
to the Rocky Mountains
um the common name is rosinweed uh we've
been looking at it as an as a potential
oil seed crop for for about 20 years
um and uh are also looking at some of
the protein functionality and its use as
it and its use as potential dual use for
forage and
um biomass production
um we look at dual cropping systems or
or multi-cropping systems so Cura Clover
is a crop that we're really interested
in
um learning about how to grow crops in
mixtures in diverse mixtures so right
now we have what we call a perennial
ground cover
program that's looking at cure clover as
a as a
as a perennial grain or sorry as a
perennial ground cover that you could
plant and then plant
um things like corn or soy into uh
without having to to turn over the soil
perennial wheat is a hybrid as I as I
mentioned before between
um the between intermediate wheatgrass
and durum wheat and so we're looking at
um developing that as a perennial grain
crop so far we've been able to achieve
two years of yield from
um perennial wheat we haven't gotten to
that third year and for us three years
is the minimum
um for considering something a perennial
um this crop here is perennial sandfoine
or sorry perennial sorghum
um which is a crop that is being worked
on uh we have a plant breeder who is
housed at the University of Georgia and
she's working on um developing perennial
sorghum
um and it's it's been pretty successful
in Uganda
um a lot of our collaborators in Africa
um have had good success with adoption
of the crop and then
um Sandpoint is this next crop it's a
legume that's been grown primarily as a
forage crop in in the west um so kind of
Montana to Idaho Wyoming
um that area and and and then up into
Canada as well and so we're looking at
actually eating the the grain or the
seed from this crop
um it's nutritionally sort of similar to
chickpea but it looks like a small
lentil
um
I don't know what Clover this is so I'm
going to skip over that and then this
crop in the top
um right is kernsa so this is the seed
or grain from intermediate wheatgrass
that um has been we've been working on
at the land Institute for about 20 years
um we also look at perennial polyculture
so we're looking at growing Alfalfa and
intermediate wheatgrass or kernsa
together in mixtures to try and provide
nitrogen for the currency from this this
inner cropping method
um and that's kind of our ecological
intensification program uh works on that
they also work on
um diseases and pests of perennial grain
crops so they're they're looking at that
as well
and we have an ecosphere studies program
that's really focused on the human
learning aspects and the cultural
development that has to happen to to
adopt perennial grain crops
um we have an international program that
is aimed really at developing new
um research connections with different
countries all over the world uh to bring
more breeding programs for perennial
grains into existence and then we have
the crop stewardship program which is is
the program that I lead and so I'll
delve a little bit more in depth into
that so our goal is to bring Nature's
economy into line with the human economy
um and our goal is to Steward diverse
perennial grain crops to farms and forks
for maximum positive impact this kind of
comes straight from the the mission of
the land Institute
to do this it takes
um a pretty a pretty robust set of
things to have happen
um we have to have an innovation and an
innovate and a whole package of
innovations that go with it folks have
to adopt that and start bringing it onto
the landscape we have to scale that and
then we also have to have this portion
you know of being seen as legitimate so
if for for crop stewardship we really
work on like this Civic and political
aspects of that so we we have um like a
policy and government Affairs person who
works on that work
we to do this you know when we talk
about like The Innovation what is the
Innovation so first of all it's a new
crop in this picture
um it's silphium integrifolium and these
are some researchers that are
collaborators from Argentina
um
we need a new cropping system so a new
way to grow these crops together
we need a new way to think about and
value the crops so people have to want
to eat them and they have to be willing
to buy them
um we have to have new ways to get them
to Market so what kinds of products are
they going to go into
um we have to have new ways of kind of
understanding how these things interact
so the genetic agronomic and cultural
aspects of evolution that that allow a
crop to come onto the landscape and be
enjoyed
um we're also thinking about new ways of
sharing power so right now the land
Institute owns the trademark license so
the trademark on the name kernsa and
we're we're working on developing a
Perpetual purpose trust that would allow
actually anyone who has a licensing
agreement to be a partial owner of the
trademark and to benefit from any
um any money or or aspects that are
coming back to this group
um and we also you know really have to
understand our relationship to the
places where these are grown and have
that be a part of what we do so the
whole thing you know is a new type of
Agriculture and a new system so this is
a picture of The Perennial rice in in
China so this is this requires an
entirely new system
um
this work is really based in kind of
this this literature around
socio-technical transitions
um towards sustainability a lot of this
work has been done in in things like um
solar energy and Alternative Energy but
we're looking at how the what has been
learned from those
um new marketplaces and and new
developments how that can be
transitioned and transferred to new crop
development so like I said it's a whole
system it's it's not just the kind of
core technology but it's also like the
infrastructure and the supply chain all
of the people it's the the understanding
of the goals and procedures and
processes and an entire kind of cultural
shift that allows for this to happen and
that usually looks a lot messier than
the picture before so I just want to
show you know that what it actually
looks like is something like this we
have you know suppliers user groups and
and there are connections between all of
these things going all over the place
um
you know I'm going to use Kearns as sort
of the example of how this work is
getting done
um in real time uh this is generally
action research so we're so we are doing
the research but we're not sort of like
sitting back and waiting for things to
happen and then like analyzing the
results we're we're actively trying to
predict what has to come next and and
act on it so kernsa is an a new variety
you know a new a new variety
um this this sort of represents what we
call The Innovation package so all of
these things have to be oops
all of these things have to happen and
have to be in place to make sure that
kearnsa goes onto the landscape and and
scales on the landscape so each of these
pieces
um is a part of the Innovation package
so we we have to have agronomics and
best practices we have to have food
science and understand everything from
like storage methods to like recipes
um product development markets you know
all of that policy and infrastructure so
making sure that the grain can actually
be sold to humans that it's safe for
them to eat we do a lot of that risk
assessment work
um and then we work on like new
ownership models and governance
techniques
so I feel like this can be well
represented by the liebec's law of the
minimum which uh sort of is this idea
that when you're moving this technology
package into the world whatever the
minimum is you know whichever
peace is the least developed of those
things that we just talked about that is
going to stifle the adoption of the
entire package it's going to mean that
that we have to address that and try and
find some way of making sure that you
know this Barrel can hold more water
so
um we want to make sure that like no
single no single piece of the Innovation
can actually move forward without having
all of it
um in place
and so we really work at in in crop
stewardship on identifying what is that
next limiting factor how do we address
it and taking action to try and address
it so that's that's sort of the action
research piece of what we do
um and then we get to kind of adoption
so this requires that we have really a
good understanding not just of like each
of the individual Innovation packages so
you know we might really we might have
seed and have the seed
um available but making sure that we
really understand you know what what is
behind the rural community who who comes
to this crop and might want to work with
this crop and how is it going to be
successful on their particular farm with
their particular management system and
all of those things
um one of the things that we really have
to think about is that why that I talked
about earlier where you're thinking
about you know the the whether it's
nitrates in the water whether it's
erosion things like that making sure
that we really understand that so we can
make recommendations about how to adopt
these crops in a way that is actually
going to address that underlying reason
for the community
um
so this this I is kind of this adoption
framework is technology transfer so this
is something there's a lot of research
about responsible technology transfer
and
um we really try to bring this to the
action research which is the adoption so
we try to pair those two things in our
in our work
um we want to make sure that we develop
relevant knowledge that we present it to
communities in a way that is that makes
sense and is accessible to them and that
we then have the hardware to kind of
back it up whether that Hardware looks
like you know a new variety of kernsa or
new processing infrastructure for making
sure that like it gets de-hulled and
cleaned
um to specifications
we do this with with through this like a
wave of Technology transfer when we
think about it you know early on you've
really got these innovators and then you
have this these folks who are early
adopters you have to get through this
kind of TR we call it the or you know in
the tech in the literature it's the
trough of disillusionment and you know I
I have conversations with folks and that
are very much about this kind of trough
of disillusionment so
um I have to I have to sort of make sure
that I understand okay we're we're
having a conversation about about the
traffic disillusionment
um at times we're really in this like
somewhere between probably early
innovators and or innovators and early
adopters right now with kernsa it's it's
been about 20 years
and that we've been working on this crop
so if you consider
you know wheat has been has been
um being used by humans for about 10 000
years really early in kind of the the
the trajectory so
um we're really working on getting
toward kind of this this early majority
and through this trap of disillusionment
so this the another way to think of it
is sort of is called the Valley of Death
this is the this is the place where
we're trying to get go from like
philanthropic or government-funded
agencies and get through this technology
transfer to where we have private sector
investment
um and larger diffusion or scaling so
this is kind of where my team and I live
on the daily is in this Valley of Death
where intermediary is trying to like put
those things together
um so scaling processes so that
diffusion piece if you look here as we
come through technology transfer and
adoption the next part is this diffusion
and this is sort of the scaling work
that we that we take on there are
different types of scaling so sometimes
we're we're looking at vegetative
scaling where or scaling out where you
know maybe the same thing that works in
Minnesota works in Kansas and maybe the
same thing that works in Kansas Works in
Wisconsin but there we also have this
kind of generative scaling so I think a
really good example is that you know in
Minnesota we have producers who are
primarily focused on the grain like they
they're really not all of them are
really interested in the fact that
kernsa also produces a large biomass and
that can be used as forage some of them
have like a either have cattle or have a
neighbor who has dairy cattle or
something like that so they're using it
but it's really not the driver for them
it really is the grain but in
um Colorado
The Growers there are kind of like yeah
maybe someday we want to get to grain
production but right now what we're
really interested in is having pastures
with with uh intermediate wheatgrass
that are more resilient to Drought than
some of the grasses that we're using now
and we're interested in kernsa because
down the line we might be interested in
the grain production but right now we're
really interested in the forage for our
cattle and so that is kind of an example
of this scaling up or this generative
um type of scaling that we see happening
um there are different kinds of
approaches to scaling for different
levels of like social and Technical
complexity and each of these operates
sort of in a different way with like
different times and locations happening
so we have like push uh scaling which is
where we have something that we we want
to scale and we work really hard to make
that happen we see this as like kind of
what our business partners do so we we
work really closely with some businesses
that have centered Kerns as a part of
their their main business and those
folks are just working really hard to
make sure that this
um that that their businesses go to
scale
we have pull
um
we have pull scaling which is where you
have kind of like an
excuse me an aspired future in mine and
there's and we're like seeking to scale
that but we think that that we're gonna
we're that
we have to scale up the individual
pieces to make sure that that future
happens so
um that's that happens kind of more from
the market side so we as the market
becomes interested we see things that we
see more Growers putting Grain on that
landscape we have plant scaling where we
have something that we want to see go to
scale but it can only happen if we
connect all of these other factors so
this is this is really I think a lot of
what
I was talking about with the way that
kurnza is getting tomorrow or getting to
scale now where we have the this
Innovation package and all of that has
to be kind of in place and we have to
develop a lot of that for it to to move
forward and then finally we have probe
scaling which is where we have an
aspired future in mind
um but we don't quite know what scaling
processes are going to get us there so
this is where I think a lot of the crops
at tli are
um because because we really haven't
explored some of the some of the scaling
um methodologies yet so Kearns is maybe
more kind of in this plant place but
most of the other crops are more in this
Pro place where we're kind of like well
we're trying to find it so we're scaling
up seeds so that we have it available
for recipe development and kind of you
know for example with sorghum the first
um sorghum beer and and whiskey were
brewed this year so that gives us some
idea like are these is this crop even
viable for these particular end uses and
gives us some idea of how we might work
with that but that's more of like
um
trying to probe like is that is this
going to work to scale it based on this
kind of pattern or not
um and then finally we work tour to
build legitimacy for all of these
perennial grain crops
um our plant breeding programs and uh
and and others really work on this
scientific space you know our
Publications and things like that
probably go into building legitimacy in
the realm of of science
um but there are all of these other
Realms that are required
um so we want to make sure that we have
like we're gaining legitimacy in the
eyes of government or legislative bodies
so that's really this policy and and
politics
um
in the legal sense we really luckily
have not had to like go through the
process of judicial reasoning so we
haven't like had had any lawsuits or
things like that that we've had to
address but we but with the
um with the trademark protection like we
we establish a legitimacy for kernsa and
for what it actually is
um in this way because if there isn't a
legal definition for a crop like there
there wasn't for kernsa someone could
sell Rye they could sell wheat they
could sell a bag of rocks and they could
just call it currenza unless you do
something like build a trademark where
you have them a legal definition for
what
um that is and then in the in the
Practical realm of building legitimacy
this is where we really work with
Farmers I would say where farmers are
getting their are developing best
practices
um they're they're doing a lot of
experimentation and trying to figure out
you know what are the best ways to grow
this crop in their particular geography
and then the crop become or the practice
becomes more legitimate because you have
folks who have been successful using it
in these ways
and then finally in the Civic sense
um this is really looking at social
movements
um and citizens and societies so this is
like how we
this is embodied by like how we're
building
um relationships with other
um Champions with other non-profits and
with other academic institutions uh to
gain legitimacy
so again
we we do research on Innovation and
adoption scaling of that adoption and
then legitimacy and this is my team kind
of does all of this stuff everything
from agronomic advising I do a lot of
agronomic advising and working with
Growers
um our Upper Midwest Hub coordinator
works a lot with
um
excuse me with with producers businesses
Etc and and builds um it does a lot of
like relationship building in the Upper
Midwest where we have a lot of work
going on
um and she's also does a lot of work
building relationships with with uh
people of color and organizations that
are led by people of color in that
region
um we also have a Market's stewardship
specialist who's really working on like
the the development of
um processing and middle of the supply
chain stuff we have a person who works
on policy and government Affairs so
developing like a policy platform that's
a brand new position that actually just
started two weeks ago
um we have a breeder who's working on
end use quality
um specifically on standpoint so so he's
he's working on leading the the process
where we get uh the what's called grass
status or generally recognized as safe
so for any new product that enters the
market
um companies want to see that it's been
that it's safe for folks to eat and so
we're working on that um for that crop
and then we have somebody who works on
seed production and does a lot of our
and makes sure that we have that we're
we're always scaling up enough of the
research seed that we can start doing
kind of end use or utilization or
processing research as the crops get
more and more ready to go
so I want to go back to this like messy
messy looking plot and and show that you
know kind of this is this is where our
team is is trying to make inroads and
and where they live kind of in these in
these connections that are happening
between you know everything from public
authorities and societal groups to
um user groups suppliers uh producer
networks Financial networks all of these
um all of our team is working kind of in
these spaces where where they're
navigating many of these these different
um connections between different kinds
of groups
and
um that's that's what I have I hope I
hope I can take some questions I like to
leave time for questions
um if at all possible so because I know
there's a lot uh of work and hopefully
something a little bit new to think
about in terms of uh what what it might
look like to be a plant reader who
doesn't do any plant breeding anymore
thanks Tessa for a great talk uh you
talked a little bit earlier about power
sharing in these like new cropping
systems you guys are developing and you
mentioned for Kearns you're leveraging
the trademark on the name to like share
ownership I was curious what are some
strategies you guys are enacting for
some of the other crops that land
Institute is developing
yeah well so far none of the other crops
um is is totally ready and to go into
the marketplace because we're still
um getting like working on getting grass
status so that generally regarded as
safe
um but I think with Sandpoint we
probably will do something similar where
I I think we will probably do a
trademark on on a a name for the Grain
in the marketplace
um
in part you know for for that crop sort
of for different reasons I think for
Kearns I was so new and there was there
was sort of no legal definition for the
for the green and we wanted to make sure
that
um
that yeah that like people were selling
it uh and that there was some sort of
quality control on on kernsa
um and I think that that's important
also with Sandpoint but the other thing
that that we run into is that you know
we've really rely standpoints have been
grown in the US for
a hundred years as a forage and there's
a forage sort of seed industry and we've
been really really
working closely with the with seed
producers who already know kind of how
to how to grow Sandpoint seed and are
really interested in this and we also
want to like make sure that there's a
way for them to
kind of have some sort of return on the
investment that they've made with with
our researchers by having you know early
Market access so I don't we're not
interested in exclusivity in in any way
like that's kind of
um antithetical to our ultimate goals
but I but I do think it is important for
us to offer
maybe some sort of limited exclusivity
or some way for those folks who've been
early research Partners to recoup on the
investment that they've made in terms of
time and energy with with us
your folks have questions and okay great
Tessa thanks again for the great uh talk
uh I was wondering the rice uh The
Perennial rice yield is quite impressive
and I was wondering is there any I mean
but it was tropical is there any place
in the U.S the southern part of the U.S
that could grow it or is it have any
chance in the uh U.S market
I mean we certainly hope so it's so the
first
um rice with perennial rice was imported
last year and so it's under quarantine
at aphis to make sure that there aren't
any diseases or things like that so
um we do we've been working with um
I think it's Louisiana state or universe
I think it's Louisiana state
um and they so they have got it under
quarantine and we're really interested
in bringing it in and they have plant
breeders who are just kind of chomping
at the bed to work to work with it for
the U.S context so
um yeah there's there's it there will
definitely need to be breeding because
we just we're much colder than the
places that it's being grown now I think
it's primarily you know southeast Asia
there are maybe five or six countries in
Southeast Asia and then um a couple
countries in West Africa where it's
being grown right now so there will
there will need to be a significant
plant breeding before it would be ready
for a U.S context
foreign
thank you
um I'm curious um especially for karenza
I'm picturing your Barrel slide which
was very very I love I like that imagery
I'm curious if you can name like the
weakest part you know
um of of the barrel of the karenza
system at the moment
yeah I think the weakest part right now
is the price because yields are low
um which we don't try to hide
um we're we're confident that yields
will improve over the next you know 10
to 20 years as we as as the breeding
improves
um but because yields are low the price
is really high and in particular with
inflation and the price of wheat having
having gone up this year uh
due to like the conflict in Ukraine
um you know when companies when
companies like when their Baseline is
down here they're kind of fined paying
for a higher priced crop for for some
kind of inclusion but when their base
price is here they this price they're
really not willing to bear and so what
we're seeing now is that we have to
think of new ways to encourage
um the adoption of the grain into the
marketplace so we're doing some creative
things
um with just developing Market marketing
material and and storytelling and a
label for for uh companies to use so
that they don't have to do all of that
stuff too which saves them a little bit
on their bottom line but also
um looking at you know there are now
government programs like the
conservation stewardship program that
will give producers a payment
um for including perennial grains in
their crop rotation and so that will
hopefully also translate into lower
being able to lower the price we're also
working with with USDA to develop a crop
insurance program for kernsa so all of
those things hopefully will will help
producers not have to take you know the
basement price but also still be able to
move that grain into the marketplace
with with some government help so
other questions otherwise I have one
Tessa um
but just looking at your circle of the
different crops that the land Institute
is working on and I'm just curious about
you know when you're working on kind of
that the bleeding edge of new crops and
cropping systems and how do you how does
the land Institute or how do you think
about how to
prioritize the resources that you have
available like decide what what what's
the
like Highest Potential new crop or
cropping system or the the region that
you most want to develop
a crop for like what what kind of
processes does the organization go
through in making that prioritization
I think that that is something that's
kind of changed so you know 40 years ago
um when West Jackson started the land
Institute
um I think that it really was about
Kansas and it was about Tallgrass
Prairie ecosystems and the goal was to
mimic those ecosystems so you know
having a legumes program was important
because we see a lot of legumes in those
natural Tall Grass prairies ecosystems
and so
um that I think was was sort of
initially how that decision would get
made
um as we become more interested and and
had more collaborators internationally I
think that to some extent you know we
that is probably changing like I'm
guessing that if we were going to add a
new program would probably be about you
know perennial maze because obviously
um
that that would have a huge impact on
um many many acres and there's a lot of
resources in terms of you know the
genome and things like that that could
be utilized for breeding
um so
I I think that yeah it's sort of changed
I think that it started out as being
really focused on like mimicking the
Prairie the Prairie of Kansas in
particular for the context of Kansas and
now I think it's that
um
the the sort of mindset has shifted
toward looking at broader systems for
for various uh various Geographic
contexts and I think that that's sort of
new I think we'll I don't I don't know
how the the organization is going to
negotiate that necessarily
um in the next couple of years but I
think that
that there's no one who's who's like
ever to saying like we need to be
partnering more broadly and we need to
be working with other crops and and
supporting you know we don't have a
perennial flax breeding program but we
are really close collaborators with
folks who do
um perennial barley similarly you know
we so
um we try and provide them with with our
understanding and knowledge of perennial
plant breeding in general
um and then they work on the specific
crop
oh thank you that's really helpful
um
anybody else have question for Tessa
thank you Tessa um I was curious you
mentioned earlier that you try to get
this deep understanding of the diverse
needs that you of the communities that
you plan to deploy some of these uh
products in and I was curious how you
balance uh catering to all those needs
and then having a clear set of program
goals
um so balancing that complexity with
developing a product
um
I think
our our job is sort of to like
understand and help contextualize and
like and and make sure that we're not
over promising or ex or telling people
like these crops are going to solve your
problem right whatever that problem is
like our goal is to say
you know
yeah try this see how it works in your
system if it's not right for your system
like that's okay we don't we we want to
know that we want to understand why we
want to we want to help that but our
goal is really to help folks
contextualize like why this might work
what what kinds of problems we might see
um
I'll use I'll use the work in Colorado
as an example
um
our I don't think that kearnza uses less
water than the than the grasses that the
these producers are currently growing
they if the water is available they
kernsa will use it right the grass will
absolutely use it intermediate
wheatgrass like it will do fine with as
much water as you give it
the thing that I really tried to kind of
put the research focus on is
in times when there isn't water
will Kearns survive in context where
these other grasses won't survive or
will it recover more quickly from that
drought stress than these other grasses
like Timothy or foxtail Garrison or
these common grasses that are being
grown there and what we're finding in
initial studies is is that yes it seems
like that happens and so that's really
what we're exploring people come to me
and they want to know like this is this
grass is going to grow with no water I'm
like no obviously it's not going to grow
in the water the goal is to
contextualize it for that specific
um and for that specific context and to
explain to people why we think
there's why we think there's a reason to
be interested in the grass
yeah I I want uh is there any uh
progress understanding the genetic basis
between why the plans being perennial
and I mean annual
yeah I think there there is
um
and I'm probably not the best person to
ask about it
um I think yeah so that's a good
question for like Lee Dahan who's the
breeder who does the work on kurza or
for shuwen Wang who is The Perennial
wheat reader they they have been Matt
you know looking at the genomes of
kernsa and and
um wheat and then the perennial wheat
which is the cross between uh Durham and
intermediate wheatgrass just looking for
exactly those kind of ties and I think
perenniality tends to be pretty complex
I don't you know
um to my under from my understanding at
least which again I'm probably not the
best person to answer this question
um it tends it
there might be a few big domestication
genes that that control perenniality but
we don't or I guess they're not
domestication genes but perenniality
genes but
um I think it also I think it from my
understanding tends to be
um a pretty complex set of genes that
allow it
all right
um well Tessa thank you so much for a
great presentation and I hope folks
enjoyed the the discussion time before
the seminar as well and yeah thank you
so much
great thank you guys so much for
listening
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu